uh a lot of other places around the  world they just fold the minute there's  any type of adversity i mean can you  imagine if he went into france would  they do anything to put up a fight  probably not um and so those folks um  you know are stepping up but it's a  there's a lot of problems i think  between now and then and i think  unfortunately it's going to end up very  very ugly  i mean guys this is a governor whose  analysis of the russian invasion of  ukraine is  the people in ukraine are are actually  uh  doing something they're trying to resist  whereas  [ __ ] french people wouldn't do anything  i mean these are some of the most base  coarse  tropes that have been floating around  for 20 years remember john kerry back  when he ran against uh george w bush for  president in 2004  um the whole idea because kerry speaks  french the whole thing was okay carrie's  a [ __ ] because he speaks french these  are such dumb tropes